herzlich willkommen zum pressebriefing
im robert-koch-institut am 23 märz mit
lothar wieler dem präsidenten des
robert-koch-instituts zunächst einige
organisatorische hinweise
wir haben das pressebriefing geändert es
findet jetzt in der regel montags
mittwochs und freitags statt mit uns im
hörsaal sind nur noch 20 kamerateams und
ein bis zwei fotografen
es sind keine weiteren journalisten mit
dem hörsaal die journalisten können uns
vorab ihre fragen per mail schicken
der grund dafür ist wie sie sich denken
können die gebotene soziale
distanzierung und der ablauf des
briefings ist wie folgt herr villa wird
einen kurzen überblick über die
situation geben und danach die fragen
beantworten die wir per mail bekommen
haben
der wähler mit ja guten morgen zusammen
guten morgen hier im hörsaal und auch
draußen bei den zuschauern zunächst wie
immer eine kurze lage einschätzung der
darstellung der informationen die uns
momentan vorliegen
zunächst die internationalen zahlen die
wir den die reflektieren den stand vom
22.10 uhr
weltweit hatten wir zu diesem zeitpunkt
283 1812 fälle gemeldet das sind 30 1771
mehr gewesen als am vortag
und insgesamt finden sich darunter zwölf
1875 todesfälle in der europäischen
wirtschafts region inklusive dem
vereinigten königreich waren das zu
diesem zeitpunkt 120 1395 fälle das sind
17 1657 mehr als am vortag
und hier wurden 7252 todesfälle gemeldet
zusammenfassend kann man sagen dass die
zahlen weiter zunehmen die epidemie
weiter stark zunimmt und ich kann ihnen
auch sagen dass inzwischen 182 länder
betroffen sind von dieser pandemie
es gibt aber auch gute nachrichten
insgesamt sind 98 1840 menschen bereits
als genesen
gemeldet worden noch einige zahlen von
einigen ländern um ihnen einen eindruck
zu gewinnen das in verschiedenen
regionen der welt diese epidemie oder
diese pandemie in verschiedenen
geschwindigkeiten läuft und das ist auch
diese regionalen unterschiede natürlich
immer weiter geben wird in italien
hatten wir gestern um 10 uhr 53.500 78
fälle das waren 6 1557 mehr als am
vortag
und es entspricht einer inzidenz von
88,5 personen pro 100.000 einwohner
dort sind bereits 4827 menschen
verstorben
in spanien hatten wir zum gestrigen
zeitpunkt 24 1926 fälle das sind mehr
als 4000 4946 fälle mehr als am vortag
und das entspricht einer inzidenz von
53,5 pro 100.000 einwohner in spanien
dort sind bereits 1326 ovid fälle
verstromen außerhalb europas nur zwei
zahlen zu nennen die wir offiziell
übermittelt bekommen im iran wurden
bislang 2610 mehr fälle gemeldet das
sind 966 mehr gewesen als am vortag
dort ist die inzidenz 25,4 und dort sind
gemeldet offiziell 1556 fälle oder die
vereinigten staaten als ein weiteres
beispiel bislang 26.000 747 fälle
gemeldet das waren mehr als 7000 123 als
am vortag das entspricht dort eine
inzidenz von 8,2 pro 100.000 einwohner
sie sehen dass weltweit
unterschiedlichen dynamiken herrschen
aber überall nehmen die fallzahlen und
auch die verstorbenen zu schauen wir nur
auf deutschland was geschieht aktuell in
deutschland wie entwickelt sich das
geschehen in deutschland hier beziehen
sich die zahlen auf heute null uhr
ich hatte ihm mitgeteilt dass wir immer
um 0 uhr die zahlen aktualisieren also
täglich
und heute um 0 uhr hatten wir in
deutschland 22 1672 kogit 19 fälle
elektronisch übermittelt bekommen über
die portale der gesundheitsämter an das
robert koch institut
das waren im gegensatz zum vortag 4062
mehr also auch hier wie erwartet
steigende zahlen
ich muss allerdings sagen dass am
aktuellen wochenende nicht aus allen
ämtern und nicht aus allen bundesländern
daten übermittelt wurden so dass der
hier berichtete anstieg der fallzahlen
nicht dem tatsächlichen anstieg der
fallzahlen entspricht
das wird sich natürlich im laufe der
woche wieder anpassen wir wissen das und
wir beziehen das in unsere überlegung
natürlich mit ein
unter den 22 1672 erkrankten waren 63
todesfälle offiziell entschuldigen 86
todesfälle offiziell gemeldet worden
bei uns in deutschland ich die gesamt
incidents entsprechend 27 pro 100.000
einwohner
aber auch hier wieder der hinweis dass
es regionale unterschiede gibt wie das
bei einer epidemie immer der fall ist
auch immer zukünftig der fall sein wird
in hamburg zum beispiel weg die inzidenz
bei 51 fällen pro 100.000 einwohner in
sachsen anhalt etwa liegt sie aktuell
bei 10 fällen pro 100.000 einwohner das
sind aktuelle zahlen die sich täglich
ändern werden was wissen wir über
diejenigen die erkrankt sind in
deutschland beziehungsweise die
verstorben sind
die betroffenen personen sind im
durchschnitt 45 jahre alt die
verstorbenen waren im durchschnitt 82
jahre alt männer sind 57 prozent der
fälle damit etwas häufiger betroffen als
frauen entsprechend 43 prozent der fälle
uns liegen für 15 1859 übermittelte
fälle klinische informationen vor die
häufigsten sind symptome sind husten bei
55 prozent der patienten und fieber 40
der patienten soweit zur aktuellen lage
einschätzung und den objektiven zahlen
die uns vorliegen
lassen sie mich noch mal ein wort zur
strategie sagen
wie sieht die systematische
bekämpfungsstrategien des robert koch
instituts aus die wir schon seit vielen
wochen propagieren und die richtig und
wichtig ist
sie beruht nach wie vor auf folgendem
dreiklang eine konsequente eindämmung
durch die wir die epidemie verlangsamen
und die zahlen reduzieren
einen schutz der besonders gefährdeten
gruppen das sind die risikogruppen also
alte hochaltrigen menschen und chronisch
kranke menschen mit vorerkrankungen und
der erhöhung der kapazität in der
ärztlichen versorgung hier spielen vor
allen dingen beratungsplätze
intensivbetten eine ganz wichtige rolle
muss noch mal sehr deutlich zu sagen es
ist und es bleibt wichtig infizierte und
kranke so früh wie möglich zu erkennen
und zu isolieren kontakte zu
identifizieren und auch entsprechend in
quarantäne abzusondern um dieses ziel zu
erreichen hat das robert koch institut
unter anderem vor einigen tagen eine
ausschreibung veröffentlicht die vor
allem auf medizinstudierende zielt sie
sollen den gesundheitsämtern vor ort bei
der kontakte nachverfolgung helfen
es gibt schon eine große anzahl von
bewerbungen der aufruf war sehr
erfolgreich und das ist gut so und ich
wurde nochmals auf alle
entscheidungsträger die landräte
landrätin oberbürgermeisterin
oberbürgermeister auch andere kräfte zur
verfügung zu stellen um dieses ziel zu
stützen
die gesundheitsämter brauchen ihre
unterstützung sie haben eine extrem
wichtige rolle bei der kontakt nach
verfolgung und dabei infekt ketten zu
brechen
ich habe aber auch ein paar gute
nachrichten neben denen dass wir mehr
ressourcen adressieren und dieses ziel
weiter verfolgen können
von den bestätigten kogit 19 fällen die
uns auf dem elektronischen meldesystem
gemeldet wurden sind mindestens zwei
1809 bis zum 22
auch genesen ausgewertet wurden hier nur
solche fälle bei denen für die
verschiedenen kriterien angaben vorlagen
also erkrankungs datum symptomatik
hospitalisierung status verstorbenen
status es handelt sich also um eine
konservative schätzung wir gehen davon
aus dass bereits mehr patienten genesen
sind tatsächlich lassen sie mich noch
zwei gruppen heute ganz gezielt
adressieren und zwar zum einen die
bevölkerung das sind wir alle
und zum anderen dass medizinpersonal wir
führen gemeinsam mit der universität
erfurt eine befragung durch seit anfang
märz
das ist ein internetportal das heißt
cosmo und die befragungen zeigen eine
sehr sehr gute und wichtige information
nämlich die risikowahrnehmung in der
bevölkerung ist deutlich gestiegen das
ist wichtig die bevölkerung muss sich
gut informieren damit sie wissen warum
sie was tun sollen
es gibt aber leider immer noch eine
kluft zwischen dem wissen der
bevölkerung und dem handeln
was heißt das handeln bitte halten sie
abstand mindestens 1,5 bis zwei meter
bitte und ich fordere sie erneut
aufhalten sie die hygieneregeln ein
händewaschen und dinis in die armbeuge
niesen beziehungsweise husten
denn dieses virus wird vor allem darüber
übertragen über tröpfchen das heißt die
ausschaltung von menschen die husten und
niesen und das können sie dadurch
verhindern
und wenn sie sich die hände waschen
verhindern sie die weiter tragen dieses
konto lösen ergänzt des virus
für das medizinpersonal entschuldigen
für das medizinische personal hat das
robert-koch-institut jetzt neue optionen
zum management von kontaktpersonen und
der medizinischen personal bei
personalmangel veröffentlicht
medizinpersonal muss demnach nach engem
ungeschützten kontakt zu kurve
erkrankten nicht mehr so lange in
quarantäne und kann bei dringendem
bedarf in klinik oder praxis arbeiten
solange keine symptome auftreten
die kliniken sollten das möglichst mit
dem gesundheitsamt absprechen
damit soll die balance zwischen
praktikabilität und patientenschutz
gewahrt bleiben
das gilt ausschließlich für das
medizinpersonal details dieser
überlegungen die wir gemeinsam mit den
ländern und anderen stakeholdern
getroffen haben finden sie auf der
website des robert koch instituts das
sind für heute meine ausführungen und
nun stehe ich gerne für fragen zur
verfügung die diesmal im vorhinein an
uns elektronisch übermittelte und ganz
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit und
dann nochmal vielen dank von mir für
ihre fragen
die erste kommt von der dpa ist schon
erkennbar dass der anstieg der
fallzahlen in deutschland abgeschwächt
wird und falls nicht wann müsste sich
das nach den verschiedenen angesetzten
maßnahmen zeigen
ja das ist eine sehr gute frage es ist
noch sehr früh das wirklich fundiert zu
beantworten aber tatsächlich führen wir
ja täglich analysen durch und wir sehen
einen trend das heißt wir sehen den
trend dass die exponentielle
wachstumskurve sich etwas abflacht
ich kann ihnen aber sagen dass ich
diesen trend wahrscheinlich am mittwoch
also übermorgen definitiv bewerten kann
aber ich bin optimistisch dass diese
maßnahmen schon jetzt sichtbar sind was
sehr früh ist will sie erst seit einer
woche
wirklich gefahren wird die nächste frage
kommt vom handelsblatt mike ryan von der
whu hat davor gewarnt vor allem auf die
einschränkungen des gesellschaftlichen
lebens zu setzen betonte die wichtigkeit
kontakte zu finden und zu isolieren
die gefahr bei den ausgangs
beschränkungen sei das wenn ihr ausgangs
beschränkungen wieder aufgehoben werden
dass sich das virus möglicherweise
wieder weiter verbreitet was bedeutet
das für deutschland und ist das nicht
typisch angesichts der tatsache dass wir
lediglich menschen mit symptomen und
kontakt zu infizierten beziehungsweise
aufenthalt in einem risikogebiet testen
können ja das ist eine sehr gute frage
ich möchte noch mal ganz ausdrücklich
sagen das ist ja die strategie die wir
seit wochen verfolgen die ich als
eindämmung bezeichnet eindämmung
funktioniert nur wenn wir weiterhin mit
aller kraft die gesundheitsämter dabei
unterstützen
kontakte nach zu verfolgen
infizierte zu isolieren das heißt das
ist ja teil dieses dreiklangs den ich
ihnen eben gerade noch mal erläutert
hatte und den ich aber in den
vergangenen wochen immer wieder
erläutert habe es reicht natürlich nicht
nur die soziale distanzierung aufrecht
sollen sondern ein kernelement ist genau
diese kontakt nachverfolgung quarantäne
von kontakten 14-tägige quarantäne von
kontakten und isolierung von infizierten
diese maßnahme müssen kontinuierlich
über den nächsten wochen und monate
kontinuierlich und stringent
weitergefahren werden das ist wichtig
und das wird wichtig bleiben und wie
sieht das mit den tests aus ja wir haben
in deutschland sehr viel test
kapazitäten gerade im vergleich zu fast
wirklich allen anderen ländern
ich betone das gerne noch mal wir haben
ja in deutschland die epidemie sehr früh
erkennen können weil wir so viel testen
und die test kapazität wird
kontinuierlich erhöht die tests selber
stehen in genügender menge zur verfügung
wir müssen weiter intensiv testen
aber es muss natürlich gezielt getestet
werden darauf habe ich auch schon oft
hingewiesen
wir müssen natürlich bestimmte
personengruppen testen das sind zum
einen diejenigen die erkrankt sind um zu
wissen dass siegfried erkrankt sind und
es sind zum anderen diejenigen die von
den gesundheitsämtern nachverfolgt wird
in rahmen der kontakt nach verfolgung um
zu wissen ob sie eben erkrankt infiziert
sind und andere anstecken können oder
nicht das sind die wesentlichen personen
und die dritte gruppe die eine große
rolle spielt für testen ist natürlich
das medizinische personal das dann
gegebenenfalls weiter arbeiten kann wenn
es eben vielleicht symptomatisch ist
aber eben nicht kurve die infiziert das
heißt wir müssen den test strategisch
einsetzen
wir werden die test kapazitäten weiter
erhöhen das ist wichtig wenn wir sonst
unsere systematische bekämpfung nicht
gezielt weiterführen können und das
werden wir auch weiterhin tun
der business insider fragt nachdem die
maßnahmen zur sozialen distanzierung des
dann verschärft wurden welche maßnahmen
bleiben überhaupt noch die aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht effektiv wehren
wenn sich die lage nicht verbessern
sollte nun wir werden zunächst mal sehen
ob diese maßnahmen helfen ich sagte dass
die maßnahmen dass wir einen trend haben
den ich noch nicht hundertprozentig
bestätigen kann dahingehend dass die
maßnahmen die seit letzter woche montag
durchgeführt wurden schon zu einer
abflachung der kurve führen
wir sehen aber auch anhand der
aggregierten daten die wir von den
mobilfunk hersteller erhalten dass
insgesamt die mobilität in deutschland
sich reduziert hat sie hat sich aber
noch nicht genügend reduziert und ich
gehe sicher davon aus dass sie sich
durch die maßnahmen die seit gestern in
kraft getreten sind oder gestern
verkündet worden und die heute in kraft
treten noch stärker wie wir noch mehr
maßnahmen sehen werden es ist wichtig
das entscheidende ist wirklich dass sich
alle menschen daran halten ich hatte
dass er eben auch noch einmal gesagt
im hinblick auf die befragung cosmo die
wir zusammen mit der universität erfurt
und anderen wissenschaftlern durchführen
das wissen der menschen ist sehr sehr
viel besser geworden in den letzten
wochen aber die umsetzung muss noch da
sein wir haben es in der hand dazu
beizutragen dass diese epidemie sieg
abflacht und die wichtigsten maßnahmen
sind wirklich abstand zu halten so dass
man keinen anderen anstecken kann und
eben so gut wie möglich zu hause zu
bleiben
abstand halten ist das gebot der stunde
das virus kann nur von mensch zu mensch
übertragen werden und darum ist dass die
ganz ganz wichtige maßnahme in der
internationalen presse wird häufig die
frage gestellt wie in deutschland die
todesfälle durch cupid 19 erfasst werden
also ob nur die gezählt werden die
direkt an cupid 19 gestorben sind oder
ob auch fälle gezählt werden in denen
die betroffenen schwere
grunderkrankungen hatten und ebenfalls
mit 19 infiziert waren es aber nicht
ganz klar ist woran sie letzten endes
gestorben sind also in deutschland ist
es so dass alle menschen bei denen kogit
19 diagnostiziert wurde
und wenn sie dann sterben sind das kogit
19 fälle das heißt wir zählen einfach
der dass der das entscheidende ist das
ergebnis des tests mit 19 3 wird nicht
unterschieden ob sie dann
grundkrankheiten hatten oder nicht
sondern im nachhinein wird erhalten wir
dann die informationen ob die menschen
grundkrankheiten hatten die verstorben
sind oder nicht wir melden alle fälle
die kurve 19 positiv sind und gestorben
sind als co at 19 sterbefälle planet
interview
fragt vor dem hintergrund dass aktuell
über eine lockerung der maßnahmen in
china berichtet wird wie bewerten sie
die lockerungen in china und mit welchen
offiziellen stellen in china befindet
sich das rk ihrem austausch ich kann
nicht im detail natürlich über die
maßnahmen in anderen ländern berichten
die offiziellen stellen mit denen wir in
kontakt stehen sind die whu und es sind
natürlich auch unsere partner das ist
das cdc das ist ja quasi das robert koch
institut in china die die bewertung
müssen wirklich die die behörden vor ort
machen das ist ganz wichtig
diese behörden vor ort haben den
überblick über das geschehen und die
chinesischen die chinesischen
wissenschaftler und behörden haben so
viel erfahrung gesammelt in den letzten
monaten dass sie sicher systematisch
vorgehen werden noch eine frage von der
dpa
könnten die relativ niedrigen fallzahlen
in den neuen bundesländern mit daran
liegen dass in der ddr bis in die 70er
jahre eine tuberkulose impfpflicht
bestimmt kann ich ehrlich gesagt
keinerlei zusammenhang erkennen
es gibt nach heutigem wissensstand
keinerlei zusammenhang zwischen einer
impfung gegen tuberkulose und einem
schutz gegen das sams krones 2 das heißt
diese frage kann ich nur so beantworten
ich kann keinen zusammenhang erkennen
und die letzte frage für heute kommt von
bloomberg welcher anteil an kuwait 19
patienten musste bisher insgesamt
stationär behandelt werden und hat sich
dieser anteil in den letzten zwei wochen
verändert
ja das kann ich ihnen im detail nicht
beantworten
meines wissens wurde in verschiedenen
presse briefings in den letzten tagen
von den einzelnen ländern darüber
berichtet diese länder wissen natürlich
am besten darüber bescheid kann ich
momentan keine angabe zu machen das war
es von unserer seite für heute
herzlichen dank dass sie dabei waren und
bis mittwoch
danke